this video is sponsored by princess
connect redive princess connect redive
global is celebrating their one year
anniversary and is one of the hottest
new recent anime games to be released
which has now accumulated over 5 million
downloads since its launch last year to
commemorate this special occasion
crunchyroll games is giving away a ton
of freebies don't miss out because you
can still get a free 10 draw every day
until february 15th and there is no
better time to get in and start pulling
as the featured banner is moiemi and
princess gala not only is muay mi one of
the key characters in the story during
her banner you can join double rates up
on all three star characters yes that's
right all three star characters finally
rate up isn't a lie if you've never
tried princess connect redive the best
time is to get on it now this
all-inclusive anime rpg is full of
beautifully animated cutscenes special
abilities and characters so if you've
seen the quality of the anime adaptation
and want to see the story that is based
on just click the link in the
description to download princess connect
re-dive today and with that said let's
get on with the video hey guys bone and
chicken master race enjoyer here it's a
new year and what a great start we've
already had looks like we might finally
get to complete the trilogy as fans get
teased a possible long-awaited sequel to
world war ii i passed the one test in
the world my asian parents are
disappointed in me for passing and the
winter anime season is in full flow with
a new year comes new hope is this going
to be 2022 or 2022 it's been two years
too long and too much damn bad news so i
think we've finally drew a break this
year you know or if not if the rest of
the year is still destined to go to [ __ ]
can we not get just a fun apocalypse
just for once
[Music]
[Music]
but i'm a jojo fan
[Music]
i know what sex is
oh no we found the one thing worse than
covered
sexist covid all right look i know what
you're thinking guy wakes up in a world
where almost all men have died out and
it's up to him to almost single-handedly
repopulate all of humanity for most men
it's an inconceivably high mountain to
climb for this guy it's almost an
impossible task for johnny sins it's
tuesday afternoon and i bet you're
sitting there thinking like something
something redo appealer something
something the amount of child support
this man would have to pay would make
elon musk bankrupt something something
this is clearly just a hentai plot no i
know we've recently just had a huge
influx of basically hentai series
playing among us with normal anime but
just think about it for a second you
have a literal apocalypse where a guy is
being pressured to commit quaitus as
many times as possible guilt-free but he
refuses so he can save himself for the
one girl he's promised to be with the
man's out there dodging [ __ ] like he's
playing a damn bullet hell all in the
name of love gentlemen this isn't hentai
this isn't even i can't believe it's not
hentai this is in fact
the most christian anime of all time
wait wait wait so you want me to sleep
with all these women to save the world
that's right so you're telling me that
the fate of the entire world
is
oh yeah baby we've got dole's front line
based on the gattra game where all your
favorite rifles have been turned into
waifus and can certainly give you an
eyeful [ __ ] boss yes it's a world
where humanity has found a way to
physically and legally [ __ ] their guns
aka the state of texas i've heard from
fans that this has a pretty good story
but no one's ever clarified if it's good
good or just gotcha game good but you
know what look at these aesthetics
listen to these tunes if i was a fan of
the game i'd be pretty damn happy people
like to compare us gacha gamers to
[ __ ] nft bros for the large amounts
of money we could spend on jpegs you
know what at least our degenerate money
is being used for projects that actually
give back to our degeneracy so what he's
saying is when you buy an nft you
technically own the nft art except
literally anyone could just barge in
right click save as and then have their
way and do whatever they want with the
art that you supposedly own yeah that's
right right if you these are just jpeg
ntr
no you know even though i try to focus
on new shows the sequel corner is
actually pretty full this season we've
got rising of the gun hero return of the
bad cg there's more vanitas you know it
takes a lot for me to watch a vampire
show and there was nothing i've really
grabbed me in season one so i'm probably
going to give the season 2 a miss
like i was saying vanitas season 2 was
always on the top right to watch list
takagi-san 3 princess connect season 2
more realist hero i know you should take
my isight opinions with a grain of salt
but this is an enjoyable show it's a
kadhi cigar right no don't don't touch
me look i'm giving out a genuine
recommendation all right i'm i'm [ __ ]
serious for once and i don't know why
everyone thinks i only ever watched damn
issa guy
yeah i don't even know what this show is
i don't know how they keep doing it but
ufo table continued to raise the [ __ ]
bar to new unimaginable heights for a tv
animator series with the new demon
slayer
thank you jeff bezos
[Music]
curtains mate you can swing from flap to
flap neck we got some cute girls you
fishing once again failing to properly
represent gentlemen for my country of
origin oh my god wait
is this it
finally
the representation i was looking for
british people holy [ __ ] this is
beautiful what is this makato shinkai
meets love live clan add by kyoto
animation cloverworks handwritten
apology for promised neverland season
two seriously though this is probably
the best looking new show this season
and it's on a slice of life about a cute
little country girl i would say more but
these visuals speak louder than i ever
could it's beautiful it's stunning it's
an absolute tree for the eyes and you
know what this is wait wait a minute
rewind that did she just
what the [ __ ] she just she just stuff
don't use nail clippers oh my god she
liked it as well bruh
brush is not even doing it on her own
[ __ ] desk
[Music]
oh god what is this she's one of them
wait a minute this is the east karma boy
connor practice dubbed in voice acting
school man i'm so [ __ ] proud of him
look you can hear him right here monkey
yes we have an isocar where a girl wakes
up to be an overpowered character in a
game she was a veteran player in in an
itakai concept we haven't seen since
overlord four years ago but we also have
leadel anisakai where a girl wakes up to
be an overpowered character in a game
she was a veteran player in in an itakai
concept we haven't seen since one
sentence ago or i'm just being facetious
this one's actually a comfy slow slice
of life isakai there's a cute girl
there's feel good vibes
there's a girl that speaks fluent hentai
genius prince now i've got to be honest
the first time i saw this i was like
wait
this is just realist hero that was like
two paragraphs ago this time you have a
lazy prince who inherits the kingdom not
in the best of states so dreaming of a
day where he can retire early he uses
his genius mind to fix up the kingdom
with the intention of increasing its
value so he can sell it eventually but
then along the way accidentally becomes
a great leader in the process it's
realist hero without the realist in the
center of it and honestly it is similar
but i'm having a lot of fun with the
civilization types fantasy fix them up
shows do you ever give your homies a
kiss goodnight do you ever tell your
bros they're looking extra submissive
and breathable today do you ever just
want to like [ __ ] your best friend
what do i have to show for you i am not
gay fantasy for shojo is a show where
two best friends get esaked but one of
the bros turns into a hot girl and as
they wake up to understand this fact
they have one grim realization about
each other
oh no
he's hot i have relationships with women
and sex with men nothing wrong with
being a bromosexual having a show that
explores your homosexuality except just
one issue they really value their
platonic friendship so it's a race
against time to find a way to return
home before they end up falling in love
with each other that's right it's jojo
fans love his war asking the question
can you suck your bros [ __ ]
if he doesn't have a dick
speaking of sucking dick yaoi now a lot
of yaoi stories i've seen have these
weird power dynamics and toxic
relationships that would give 50 shades
of grey a run for its money and if
that's put you off in the past then i
present to you sasaki and miano aka
blind to you it's just a healthy yowie
romance story i mean just look at this
the man is so pure he's literally
[ __ ] out bubbles it's cute it's
wholesome and it's just nice to see a
healthy vanilla relationship developed
between an innocent bl lover and just
your average guy who really really
really wants to play super smash bros
you know as much as i'm normally excited
about the prospect of an anime original
show i remember the last time
cloverworks took on this many shows in a
single season and uh
well just look at that one turned out
you've got some kind of minority report
style story and an alternate history
japan with a bunch of augmented dudes
who can parkour this looks like it could
be a decent show but i'm coming in very
cautiously because this is clover works
third show and i think it's clear where
all their attention is going this season
i don't know where this will rank in the
overall shows that cloak works are
producing this season but it will
definitely be in the top three okay next
show let's see what this is
well hold on a second let me just grab
some snacks
all right what i
missed actual show approaching sabiki
bisco is a new show from a new studio
formed by guys who worked on shows like
fate stay night the evangelion movies
cowboy bebop and perfect blue and it is
the craziest new show this season set in
a post-apocalyptic world gone mad this
is a dora hedorah mad max journey
through pure insanity and i am here for
it it's the type of show where you see
something like
that
and you're like oh okay that must be
some anime slang name for a special
strike squad they have or something
okay
it was actually just [ __ ] hippos you
see policemen riding iguanas gun toting
hippos engaging a chase sequence with
that [ __ ] crab dance crab there's a
guy shoots arrows that spawns mushrooms
that takes on a gun plane controlled by
a slug the show follows this crazy
internal logic if you dream it you can
probably see it here but for some reason
it works there's a sense of coherency
behind all the madness i have absolutely
no idea what to expect going forward
with this series but you can bet your
ass i'm gonna be strapped in on the ride
bruh
bruh
must watch must watch this has now gone
into a must-watch
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] was that
what was that they had us the first half
i'm not gonna lie there's a comfy
policewoman slice of life apparently
this one was written by someone who has
real working experience in the police
force for 10 years and i absolutely
believe it because it would have taken
10 years to actually see this many
crimes being committed in japan
what's going on here then
the strongest sage with the weakest
crest sounds like a name that was auto
generated using google trends a show so
generic so forgettable that i actually
forgot it was an anita guy i mean just
look at this we got strongest harem
fantasy reincarnation having the worst
power that's actually the best an
academy training generic mc a [ __ ]
tournament talk and this is just the
first [ __ ] episode guys we're
literally one easter car away from
setting a 90 trash speedrun record
alright here's the big one my dress up
darling was one of the most hotly
anticipated show this season and you
know what
i can see why i haven't seen a feel-good
slice-of-life romance that's hooked me
this quickly since horry mia except
along with the wholesomeness it has this
so what does that make it
horny mia
okay man i'm gonna have to ask you to
leave now i absolutely love the
chemistry between two leads
complimenting each other while also
being complete opposites in their own
way and you know what i'm gonna say it
maren is far and beyond the best girl of
the season and it ain't even a [ __ ]
competition like get this [ __ ] out of my
face we're making space for the real
queen now i've heard some slanderous
claims that i'm simply calling marin
best girl of the season because she
reminds me of my real life fiance and i
would like to quell these preposterous
rumors immediately look guys i don't
like every blonde anime character just
because my partner has blonde hair okay
come on you gotta look deeper than that
that's like saying every blonde anime
girl with blue eyes is a transfer
student character from america which
they are but shut up see maren is an
eccentric outspoken girl who isn't
afraid to speak her mind and sydney is
well she's not like that at all not also
forgetting that she's a cosplayer who's
not very experienced in making costumes
and that's a characteristic that's just
completely unique to her not forgetting
most importantly she's a fan of hentai
games saying things like yeah it's a
naro gay but it's epic and
i couldn't see sydney saying that line
at all look guys my dress-up darling is
just a great show with a great girl and
just one of the shows you should be
watching right now because these two are
clearly going to be the best couple of
the year and that is my own personal
purely unbiased opinion coming from my
sharpened instincts of years of watching
great romance anime and nothing else
alright who the [ __ ] made this
[Applause]